هذا هو iPhone 10s ، وهو أكثر
أجهزة iPhone التي أنشأناها تطوراً على الإطلاق ، وهو
مصنوع من الفولاذ المقاوم للصدأ من الدرجة الجراحية
، وله طلاء ذهبي جديد رائع من
الأمام وعلى الزجاج هو
أجمل iPhone صنعناه على
الإطلاق.  شاشة OLED مقاس خمس نقاط ثماني
بوصات على القطر وكما
ترى تقول شاشة أكبر مثل
الهاتف ذو الحجم الزائد ولكن في تصميم أصغر جيدًا ،
فإن iPhone 10 s ليس فقط حجمًا واحدًا ولكن
بحجمين للعرض 5.8 بوصة و
6.5 بوصة جديدة  شاشة Super Retina ،
فماذا نسميه هاتفًا أكبر من
الحجم الزائد ولكننا نطلق عليه iPhone 10s Macs
، وقد قام الفريق بمطابقة مكبرات الصوت القوية
مع البرامج الرائعة لتقديم
تجربة صوت أكثر ثراءً ، لذا فإن مشاهدة
الأفلام تبدو مذهلة ، هذا 812
الأيوني بلا شك  أذكى
وأقوى شريحة في أي هاتف ذكي على الإطلاق ،
ستندهش تمامًا
من الصور التي يمكنك التقاطها
باستخدام iPhone 10 s وهي الكاميرا ، لذلك
عندما تلتقط الصورة بوضع عمودي
ثم y  إذا انتقلت إلى تطبيق الصور ،
فاضغط على "تعديل" ، سترى شريط تمرير جديد
في الجزء السفلي يوضح العمق ، نعم
قال أحدهم لا استعد لهذا لأنك
دعني أفجره ، عليك أن تشاهد
شيئين في وقت واحد ستشاهده
العمق وستشاهد
الخلفية يمكنك بعد التقاط
صورة ضبط عمق المجال
[تصفيق]
وتتغير الخلفية
معها وهناك شيء آخر قام
به الفريق للاستفادة من
الميكروفونات الأربعة المدمجة في iPhone 10s  يمكننا
تسجيل صوت ستريو مع مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بك
أيضًا ، يبدأ من 999 دولارًا
.